- [Kelly] Hello.
(audience applauds)
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm so good.
I mean, I said scary scene,
but that bath kind of looked magical.
- Well.
- Like what's the story?
Did you forget it was on?
- Alright.
Every single season,
oh, and there's only
been two seasons so far,
myself and Don Mancini, the
creator of the Chucky series,
we like to take a naked bath together,
for social media!
(audience laughs)
And you know, and Don is conveniently gay
so he's not interested
(kelly laughs)
in me in that way.
- Conveniently gay,
- Yes.
- that's amazing, okay.
(person in green shirt claps)
- [Audience] Woo!
This was, this season,
I was like, oh, I wanted
to make sure that I had
a lot of bubbles to cover my its and bits
because I have more its
and bits than usual.
Nobody wants to see them.
So I put a whole jug of
bubble bath in the bathtub,
and then I turned on the jacuzzi,
and I went out of the
room just for a second,
and then I came back
(Kelly laughs)
and obviously it did the trick.
But the good thing is,
there were lots of bubbles.
More than enough bubbles.
- [Kelly] It kind of looks amazing.
- Yes, and you know what?
Everybody's jealous 'cause Don and I
do our little naked bathtub scene
and they all wanna be in it.
But I think if you have other
people in the bathtub scene,
it becomes salacious.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
If you have like the straight guys
- Not a conveniently gay man.
- in the bathtub scene,
it becomes like a weird
(Kelly laughs)
sexual harassment thing.
Like, "Jennifer Tilly made
us take naked bath with her!"
(laughs) Human resources! Yes.
(all laughing)
- Favorite part of today
is conveniently gay.